- Good afternoon everyone,
and welcome to the session.
Great to see so many people here today.
My name's Bharat Mistry.
I work for Trend Micro.
And over the 40, 45 minutes,
we're gonna kind of look at
why it's important to recognize
that actually cyber
risk is a business risk
and something that needs to be
tackled in a business manner.
And what we're gonna do
is we're gonna dive into a
number of things actually.
I suppose in today's cloud
and really, AI driven world,
innovation growth has to go
hand in hand with security,
especially when we look at
the regulatory landscape
that sits right now around AI,
the privacy, the data and everything.
They have to go together
because breaches can
become expensive, right?
The question is how do
you manage that innovation
and growth without that disruption?
And that's what this session aims to do,
is to kind of look at some
strategies around that.
What we'll do is we'll cover
some practical insights,
some real world outcomes,
and really kind of how AWS
and Trend Micro can empower
proactive risk management
because that's the kind of
the name of the game here.
And we'll take a kind of
meandering tour as we go through,
and we'll look at really
what does today's security
environment look like,
the approaches that have been adopted,
and the problems that it has created
for all organizations, right?
We'll then think about the
mind shift change required
to go to proactive and
why we wanna do that.
We'll look at things
like communicating risk
to non-technical stakeholders,
so outside of the security
team or the IT team,
and really why something like
a platform-based approach
is really needed to kind
of have a true visibility
of your enterprise and what's going on.
And we'll finally end
off with a case study
with Northeast Georgia Health System
who are actually
transforming cyber security
in their environment to
be a business enabler.
Hopefully, we'll have some time at the end
for some Q&A as well, so
let's see how we go on.
So in light of kind of recent
high profile cyber attacks
that we've seen, like certainly in the UK,
most people will know about
Jaguar and Land Rover.
I think recently in the US
with Bridgestone as well.
It's had some major impact.
If we look at just JLR,
the direct impact on
them was $220 million,
five weeks loss of production.
So you can imagine the
state of that organization,
everything shut down for five weeks.
That's huge, right?
For a manufacturer where
you've got piling stock,
you wanna get that money out,
you've gotta sell those assets.
More importantly, you've gotta
think about the disruption
to the supply chain as well.
In many cases, some of
those niche suppliers
that supply JLR have gone bust.
So not only is it an impact
on you as an organization,
but who do you partner with?
And then really lastly,
it's the cost to get
them out that situation.
They had to take a 1.5 billion
pound loan from UK government
to kind of rectify the situation.
So you can see in every
boardroom right now,
it's become a war room
for managing cyber risk.
And I suppose we need
to kind of peel back,
what do we mean by cyber risk?
I think at its core, it's
really an operational risk.
We've gotta think about moving
the conversation beyond IT
or beyond technology
and moving it back into an
operational kind of context.
And I'll give a bit bit
of detail behind this.
So for example, in the UK,
the National Cybersecurity Center,
they're calling and they wanna advocate
something called resilience engineering
or business resilience.
And this is where cyber needs to come in
because it's about the ability
to provide core and critical services
and applications whilst
under any kind of disruption,
being able to absorb that pressure
and maintain those critical
services whilst under attack.
That's very different to
where cyber's being seen.
Cybersecurity has always been
about prevention in the past,
but what we are looking to do now
as we talk about business risk,
it's moving it into a
conversation around resilience
and into business continuity,
'cause that's the name of
the game now I would say.
Certainly, on the
resilience side of things,
it's very much a differentiator.
And just going back to
what the NCSE was saying,
they're actually advocating
that in worse case scenarios,
you assume that no IT is available
and you have to go back
to paper-based systems.
And that's quite a big step,
and a bold step that needs
to be tested and tried.
And it tells you this is more
than just a technology issue.
It is now become a people
and a process issue as well.
And these are the kind of differentiators
that really start to matter.
So when we think about the reality
of modern cyber risk.
Actually, before I talk
about the risk itself,
if you think about most organizations,
there are four pillars
that the board will always
focus and center on, right?
First it's growth, right?
Having that revenue, going
back to shareholders,
and making sure that we
are growing the business
in the right way.
Hence we've got kind of
innovation through cloud
and AI happening right now
is to give you that
competitive edge, right?
That growth is underpinned
by customer trust.
That's the fuel factor
that drives the growth
engine for any organization.
If you've got trust in your customers,
they're gonna buy from you,
they're gonna innovate with you
and take that forward.
And customer trust is
largely based on compliance.
They wanna know that anything
that they're acquiring,
they're buying, they're
using is compliant.
So if you buy, for example,
any electronics in the UK,
you'll always get a CE badge
to tell you it's at a certain level
or a certain standard, right?
And then lastly, it's
around operational risk
or operational resilience.
And the factor
that connects all of these
four pillars together
is cyber risk.
Because if you get cyber risk wrong
and you don't manage it in the right way,
it has a direct impact on all of them.
Just going back to the
growth pillar alone,
it can severely hamper innovation.
By any breach, it could lead
to a compliance friction,
it could lead to other activities
which you would never foreseen
and delay that go to market.
Same in things like regulations as well.
Regulations are getting
tighter as I spoke about,
and having a breach has a
material impact on that,
which is linked to the
operational resilience
because any outage will carry downtime,
and potentially high costs as well.
Not just loss in business,
but also penalties that
could come out of it as well.
So you can see, cyber risk
is a integrating factor
that kind of drives all
of these things together.
So the question really
now comes to saying,
well, why does it matter right now?
And there are a number
of different things behind this, right?
It kind of, I suppose at its base level,
it kind of signals the start
of what we call shared
responsibility and accountability
where cybersecurity outcomes
influence executive pay
and corporate governance.
So let's just take a step back here.
What was just an IT issue
is now being taken right up the stack,
right up to the board.
And I would say every business
unit owner is accountable
for the data and the systems they manage.
And if you wanna see a
real world example of this,
Qantas, they cut executive bonuses
by 15% recently on the back of the breach
that they suffered.
So you can see that
corporate responsibility
is going all the way to the top.
So there's a vested
interest at the board level.
Cyber risk is no longer delegated,
it's actually collectively owned.
And going back to what I said earlier,
it's gotta go hand in hand
with that innovation and growth
to have that security element there.
And when we think about
this innovation and growth,
this is a hot theme right now.
AI is reshaping every
business as we see right now,
new business models, new insights,
new go to markets, right?
It's allowing you to do things
faster, quicker, cheaper.
But as you can see from the stats,
there are some concerns here, right?
We see two kind of two
sides to a coin I would say.
On the one hand, we see
in organizations use AI
to boost that kind of
efficiency and competitive edge.
But on the other hand,
and you can see the figure up
there, 93% express a concern
around the increased security risks
both by not only internal use,
but also third party developed capability.
I talked about the supply chain earlier,
and in this context, it's
that software supply chain,
that software bill of materials.
How do you know what the exposure is?
How do you vet what is coming
into your organization,
and what does it leave you open to?
This duality underscores
the kind of balancing act
that organizations are under.
It goes back to my opening statement
about how do you manage
innovation and growth
with the right security
or the guardrails to
kind of get you there.
And I suppose what it boils down to really
is having some robust
risk management strategies
when integrating innovations like this
into your organization,
and that's what we're gonna dive into.
Again, for a bit more context,
let's have a look at why
does this actually exist
and why is it so complex right now?
This is a picture
of the kind of what we
call the tax surface.
And I would say maybe five years ago,
probably been less than that.
Certainly pre-pandemic,
everything was on premise.
So from an organizational point of view,
you had your arms around all those assets,
you knew what you were controlling,
all your people were working in an office,
all your assets predominantly
would've been in the data center,
but there could be some in the cloud,
but you had a good handle
on what's going on.
Certainly, throughout the
pandemic and post-pandemic,
we've seen this accelerated
growth of the earth tax surface.
We've seen use of SaaS
applications at a level
that we've never seen before.
If you think about just AI
applications, ChatGPT, CoPilot,
and all that, over the
last kind of 15 months,
you've seen that acceleration.
I've talked about their supply chain
and third party already as well,
more and more as they become
digital in their nature.
How do you control,
how do you manage that,
how do you know what's going on?
Work from home is an attack surface
that has exploded I would say.
Organizations are struggling
to get their employees
back into the office
because hey, I could get up
at six o'clock in the morning,
do a couple of hours work,
and then have a good few hours off, right?
Everyone wants that kind of flexibility.
But that home environment
alone introduces complexity.
If you think about the
devices that could be there,
there could be unmanaged devices,
you've got PlayStations on there, right?
You've got all these other
kits, people with smart fridges.
Why would you want a smart fridge?
I dunno, but it doesn't make sense.
But you can see that there
is an opportunity certainly
for a threat actor or a hostile person
to breach one of these devices.
And we've seen these reports already.
They're easily broken into,
home routers, smart TVs,
and then it's just a lateral hop
onto what would be a corporate device
and you tunnel back through.
IoT/OT, that's a known issue as well.
Cloud native apps and
services is on the incline.
The use of non sanctioned applications
and the risks they introduce as well.
And then lastly,
we've kind of spoken
about AI already, right?
So how have organizations tackled
managing this kind of
complexity in the past?
It's been done like this.
Actually, there's three
parts to the equation,
but they've always defaulted
to the easiest one.
It's really a people problem,
it's a process problem,
but everyone's jumped onto
the technology bandwagon
to address this problem.
And there's no kind of blame here.
I would say the people
to blame could be vendors
like Trend Micro, I suppose,
who create the hype,
say you need this technology,
there's a bit of FUD,
fear, uncertainty and
doubt in all of this,
and trying to promote those sales.
So what we end up doing
certainly as organizations,
we end up buying technology for specific,
very specific use cases.
If you think about it,
like on an endpoint,
you'll buy some anti-malware capability,
you might buy some DLP capability.
Lo and behold, someone says actually,
you need some EDR capability.
And all of a sudden, I've got
three tools on that end point.
We've seen organizations with firewalls.
There was a mantra,
I would say probably six years ago.
You need dual skin firewalls
from two different vendors
based on the kind of fear
that actually if one was compromised,
the other one wouldn't.
Or if there's a vulnerability
in one firewall,
they wouldn't be in the second, right?
And we see that through things
like sandboxing technology,
cloud technology.
And more often than not,
these are, I would say
dependent best of breed tools.
And you'd be right in
your mindset thinking,
"Oh, I'm gonna buy the best of breed,
it's gonna protect me for this."
And yeah, that's probably
the good way of doing it.
But the investment required is quite high.
And the real kind of proof
of the pudding is here,
when we are under attack
or even before an attack,
and we start to ask these questions,
and these aren't technical
questions, these are questions
that the board might ask or
a non-technical stakeholder.
We say are we in danger?
What happened?
How many resources have we got?
And what should I do next?
Invariably this happens, right?
You jump from console to
console, manual processes
because doing things, that's
the only way you could do it
unless you've got a team that
can do integration for you.
And the repeatability factor goes away
because that IPR sits
with that individual.
If you've got junior staff coming through,
how are they ever gonna learn?
Or they build their own kind of IPR stack.
The thing is, it's unique
in each environment
and you just cannot replicate that.
And we end up in this kind of scenario.
Risks, threats, and infections
are absolutely impossible to see.
Now, you imagine
that, that could be an
on-premise environment.
But what if you are in cloud, multi-cloud
and third parties as well?
How do you create that true picture?
It causes a problem, right?
And it leads to, I would say
this kind of scenario here,
leaders are struggling and
it's no real surprise, right?
When we are talking
and we are communicating
about risk, it comes down
to posture and understanding the posture.
These independent tools
don't give you that.
They give you alert and
telemetry information.
And that leads on to that second point.
It's demonstrating the
return on investment.
More often than not, certainly in my time,
I've worked with a lot of organizations
that have bought the latest and greatest,
and they've never deployed
anywhere near 30 to 40%
of their tech.
Not only the the licenses,
but the capabilities as well.
They've bought it for a very tiny use case
and they've never used it.
In some cases, it's
been left as shelfware.
So how do you demonstrate
that return on investment?
And the last is really,
it's linking exposure back
to what I would say service chains
or those business critical assets.
I see something, I've got some technology
that I've got from this vendor,
something happens on there,
how do I know which tier
one services it's affecting?
How do I know it's not affecting my ERP?
How do I know it's not
affecting my e-commerce site
or anything like that?
So you can see where kind of leaders are
in this kind of situation.
And we'll kind of dive into some.
These are the challenges
that we see right now.
Those independent tools
that I talked about.
I've worked in organizations
where they've had 40 plus tools,
and it's meant
that they've had to have
three full-time employees
just doing tool maintenance.
Just think about that,
three FTEs just managing
and maintaining your
security infrastructure,
not doing any triage,
not doing any analysis,
they're just babysitting, watering
and feeding that environment.
I mean that's expensive, right?
Second problem is you've
got these siloed tools,
and you end up in this situation,
where you've got alert overload.
There's just so much coming through.
Where do you even begin?
How do you even actually say,
oh, a critical on this
tool here is the same
as a critical on that tool there.
Do the two of them come together,
and do you get a true
picture of what's happening?
You might do, you might not
unless you've done some integration.
So you end up with these visibility gaps
in your organization.
And it's kind of partly led
unless you've got those
complex integrations right
in the first place, it's a nightmare.
You think about when you
do a change in the stack,
the impact it could have.
So think about an endpoint.
You might have anti-malware,
you might have DLP,
you might have media
control, you might have EDR
and you might have a
management agent on there.
That's five, right?
So if you update one, what's
the impact on the others?
So you can see where we are,
and we end up this in this scenario
where costs are spiraling.
They're actually very high,
and the alignment back to the business,
going back to what I was saying
about exposure is very low.
So the result, you end up with this,
reactive security kind
of waste time and budget.
Reactive approaches, they
kind of lead to firefighting
after the incidents occur.
It's time consuming and it's expensive.
Unplanned responses often require,
I would say emergency fixes,
depending on whether
you can do it yourself
or whether you've got a service
organization to help you.
There is operational disruption
in all of this, I would say.
And it's no surprise, right?
Business leaders struggle
to quantify the exposure
and making it hard to
prioritize investment.
So when you're out there
saying we need this capability,
it's really difficult
because they just see this
as it's just sunken costs,
which isn't delivering any
value back to the business.
It's just a bottom line cost,
like an insurance policy
that you might use, you might not, right?
And without kind of I would
say measurable outcomes
and some predictive metrics,
security investments,
as I said, they don't
really mean anything.
So what do we actually need?
Lemme grab a sip of water.
We need to fundamentally kind
of rethink how we do security.
We need a mind shift change,
certainly to move away from where we are.
And I think really the best way to do this
is to really go up the stack again
and think about actually what
drives boardroom funding.
What is the board,
and what is a business
actually interested in?
And again, it comes down
to I would say these are
three core pillars I see.
There are others,
but it's materially down to these three.
It's around reducing that material risk.
I'm not talking about cyber,
I'm talking about risk across the board.
All organizations have a
corporate risk register,
and there's an appetite
against each of those risks.
Is it something that I cannot live with,
and I'll do something about it?
Is it something I can kind of tolerate,
or is it a risk where I
just put my head in the sand
and hope nothing happens?
It's one of those scenarios, right?
But ultimately boards, they wanna invest,
really where risk reduction
protects the business
and the value.
That's the core to it.
And this is about the alignment
of your security strategy
into that process.
It's also about lowering the
run costs and complexity.
Going back to that
scenario I talked about,
where you've got 40 plus
tools, it's complex,
the operational side of
it, maintenance side of it,
it is super complex and it
adds, I would say exposure
that you wouldn't really
want in an organization.
And measuring those threat
metrics back to business impact
is difficult as well.
I spoke about it before.
And the last bit is really
increasing the value
or the speed to value,
so faster delivery,
giving better outcomes,
and really giving confidence to the board
because they're ultimately
gonna have to respond
to shareholders and say "Yeah,
we've got this level exposure
and this is how we're dealing with it."
So we need to actually think
about how do we put
something like this in play,
or what kind of strategy could we use?
And one model that I've used in the past
is a maturity model.
So on the left hand side,
we've got varying degrees of maturity,
and on the vertical side, we've
got situational awareness.
Situational awareness is what's happening,
what should I do to combat that,
and what's going to happen, right?
What's happening, what should I do next,
and what will happen after that?
It's anticipating all of that.
And you can see we've got
this kind of growing chart
where I suppose where
you've got low maturity
and just got those tools,
you're just taking alert information in.
Your maturity level's low,
and it's very low on that
situational awareness
'cause all you're seeing
is just alert information
and nothing else.
As we start kind of going up that curve
and looking at dynamic data,
so let's say vulnerability
information for example,
we start to get a picture
of actually what could I be open to?
And we see patching regimes
and things like that which
kind of get you partly
on the front foot.
But really, where the
differentiator really starts
to kick in is understanding risk.
What does that exposure
mean in my business,
and how can I relate it
back to something tangible?
And when we start to map
what I call actionable
intelligence on top of that,
it really does kind of drive some value.
I'm in a vertical like pharma for example.
We see something happening with our peer,
we've got some intelligence,
we know it's this kind of campaign,
we see these kind of tactics.
If I know that beforehand,
I can start doing something about it.
And as we kind of start
going up the chain,
we can think about
actually reporting as well.
And people often forget about this,
reporting those metrics
in a way that makes sense,
reporting and against
how are we doing today,
how are we doing tomorrow,
and what's our projection likely to be?
And the analysis behind it.
And I suppose what we're trying to do here
is we're creating a journey path
to proactive risk management.
'Cause if you start putting
these blocks in play,
we get this kind of side
benefit that comes from it.
The time to fix dramatically increases.
We've seen recent studies
right now to every year,
probably gonna do it,
and it's still kicking around 240 days.
Mean time to detect, mean time to contain,
mean time to respond.
If you can get on the front foot,
and what I mean is if you can understand
what's open right now,
the impact it can have,
and start remediating them
before anything happens,
you dramatically reduce that time to fix.
You're only then kind
of responding to things
that you would never foresee really.
And that makes a big difference.
It goes back to the previous
slide, those three pillars.
This helps you kind of address,
give you a tick box against all of them.
So when we think about it
from a security perspective,
what are the mind shift
changes we need to think about?
We need to actually move
from that reactive defense
to a more proactive risk-based approach.
It's like if you buy a house, right?
You do risk management
every day in your own heads.
You buy a house.
I've spent so much money,
I've only got like, let's say $1,500 left
to secure the home.
Where do I begin?
You'll automatically say,
"Actually, I'm gonna
protect my front door first,
and I'm gonna put two or three things.
I'm gonna put a bolt in,
I'm gonna put a five lever lock in,
I'm gonna put maybe some CCC
TV in or a Ring doorbell.
But I've got a window up in the attic.
I'll leave that alone
because I know no one's
gonna go up there, right?
They're not gonna take the
time to break in and do that
because the risk is too high."
And that has to be the same
when we're looking at security.
Gotta take that approach.
Second thing is you've gotta move away
from those independent tools,
and look at an integrated platform,
somewhere where you ingest the data once
and then it can be shared
across a number of different capabilities
to drive different outcomes,
whether it's reactive data,
whether it's exposure management,
whether it's trying to
predict what could happen.
And last, it's about really mapping
that technical information into
business relevant insights.
When the question is
asked, what's our exposure
in terms of our Tier One services,
that's what we're talking about.
It's knowing that these alerts,
mapping onto these
applications, onto this compute,
onto this storage,
onto this part of the
network has an impact.
So what we really need is security
that's gonna adapt to your business.
And what we're trying to do really here
is make security a vehicle
to drive those innovations
in a secure manner.
Not the department of know, not
that kind of reactive model,
but actually allow you to
innovate in a way that says,
yeah, we can use cloud, we can use AI,
we can do agentic or autonomous
and know that we are
covered on these guardrails.
And it begins with things
like having total visibility,
especially in the kind of hybrid context
that we've seen now where you've got data
and applications on premise,
data and applications out in public cloud.
A need to have that true
picture be it across,
I would say identity.
So people think identity is
all about humans, but it's not.
In this new kind of AI world,
it's non-human identities
that we need to think about as well.
There's NHIs, how many people,
actually just as a quick show of hands,
how many people treat non-human identities
as a human identity that you
would then do kind of moves,
ads changes and revoke privilege?
And oh, one person, you're brave.
But people forget, they completely forget.
And it's same with like AI agents,
you've gotta treat them as humans
because they're kind of augmenting
what a human employee would do.
You need to take that kind of
risk driven approach as well.
I talked about looking at your house
and assessing where the risks are
and then putting your
investment in those places.
And that's what really matters here
is to get the best bang for your buck,
you've gotta put it in the
right place to give you
that kind of deliverable outcome.
And then it's that
strategic alignment as well,
those priorities that
actually lower costs,
that actually drive to the
business forward as well.
Oh come on, why isn't it working?
So one of the vehicles that we can use
is actually measuring risk,
and a very specific form of it
called cyber risk quantification.
Let's start off by actually saying
why do we wanna measure it, right?
It's about the very end pillar,
it's about decision making.
You wanna measure the risks
so you can actually answer
these questions around hiring,
around justifying the budget that you want
for your projects, for your
transformation programs,
the insurance choices that you might make.
Those investment decisions
are based on some tangible information,
but actually, those decisions are based
on two other assessments
or two other pillars here.
Assessment is also key.
You need to kind of have a view
of what does a posture look
like in the environment.
You need to look at the likelihood
of incidents I would say.
So techniques like threat modeling
where you might use something
like pasta as a framework.
You need to understand how
might an attacker infiltrate,
and then laterally move
around the organization,
and what's the chance of that happening,
what could over time as well?
And then it's about the communication bit.
It's about linking the two together
from the security team
talking predominantly speeds
and feeds to actually
talking to a language
that non-technical stakeholders
such as business unit owners or the board
are likely to understand,
people like the CFO, legal,
and really translate it in
a way that comes out to,
I would say outcomes for the business
in terms of operational resilience.
And if we look at how risk
management is done right now,
in most organizations,
people are in these three
bubbles I would say right now.
People have either done custom
reports either using Excel.
Excel's a great tool, but I've
seen a lot of people do that.
But it's only in that
instant in that time, right?
We've seen manual compliance
reports happening as well.
Again, it's in that instance, that time.
And certainly in these two areas,
I've seen external auditors come in
because organizations
just don't have the skills
or the knowhow how to do risk management
ought to do an audit.
And so we see these,
I would say scorecards are now coming out.
They're basic in their
nature, very external focus,
no real insight into I would
say what your attack surfaces.
You don't really know the
algorithms they're using.
So we've seen some automation,
but it's not good enough.
Where we need to get to
is these three pillars.
We need some kind of continuous scoring,
so you know what's going on.
Your cloud and AI environment is agile,
it's dynamic, it's either
changing left or right
or growing, shrinking,
so you need a scoring capability
that maps that as well.
You need to understand where you are
in terms of compliance as well.
Your developers might be
bringing up new services
and using data in different ways.
Are we violating anything?
Do we need to know?
If you think about it in the AI context,
if you think about the
prompt that someone uses
and puts PII information in there,
what have we violated in one go?
So you've gotta have an
indication of what could happen.
And then ultimately, it's
cyber risk quantification.
And what I mean by that is
actually mapping the risk
to some kind of tangible value,
and we'll look at some
of that in a minute.
So risk scoring in terms
of cyber risk exposure,
we can think of it in two ways, right?
First of all, it's the environment itself,
looking at the wide kind of asset types
that we have out there,
the range of data sources.
You may even wanna do things
like comparison to peers
to understand what are
my competitors doing
in this place and how do they stack up?
You wanna know about trending over time.
'Cause once you get that
kind of information,
you can track it over time.
You can use it as a basis
for the communication
to those non-technical stakeholders.
What are the weak spots?
What's the most important
mitigations we need to address?
What's our exposure look like over time?
Are we getting better
or are we getting worse?
That's a common question
I see in a lot of boards.
The question is how do
you kind of answer that?
Do you put your finger up in the air
or do you prove it with
some tangible data?
And this is where kind
of risk quantification
really comes in.
There are various models out there,
but the most popular one
that I've seen certainly right now
is a model called factor
analysis of information and risk,
or FAIR model.
And what we are looking
to do here is go away
from that finger in the air model
to actually putting some
quantitative metrics
around what could be
happening in the environment.
So you're looking at information
like loss event frequency,
you're looking at the kind
of threat event frequency,
the vulnerabilities that are
open, the loss magnitude.
This looks probably very
similar to the actuarial tables
that insurance companies use.
I know at the moment,
cyber insurance doesn't use
any actuarial based tables,
but this is what we're trying to do
because once you're armed
with this information,
you can take a very different view.
As you can see from the
curves on the right hand side,
we've got like a low, a
maximum, and a medium point.
And what we can do is we can
actually start mapping these
into some specific scenarios.
Here we can see ransomware with encryption
or data breach with
exfiltration as two examples.
What we're effectively doing
is creating a spectral range
that the business can understand.
'Cause if you think about
your chief risk officer,
business risk officer, that's
what they're gonna be doing.
They're looking at scenarios like this
and trying to understand what
could be the minimum hit,
what could be the maximum hit,
and what's the likelihood right now
based on our current posture?
And you can see in these scenarios,
they're just the ransomware alone
because it's quite topical,
12.3 million based on alert
and telemetry information
that we see in your environment.
And it equates to about
18% of your annual revenue.
That's the language, that's the business
that the board will understand
and will justify your security budgets
or your programs that
you're looking to do, yeah.
And we can see some of the
outcomes that come out of it.
It's very much, I would say
the language of the business.
It's informing decisions
and investments, that's key.
Now you're kind of saying something based
on some tangible facts,
based on your environment
and mapping it back
to some business context.
What you're also doing is really,
I would say influencing business
including non-cyber decision makers
where the key of the problem is really.
I talked about it earlier
about saying cyber risk
is a shared model now,
and it's things like this,
which will obviously help going forwards.
So, thinking about that mind shift change,
we really need to be thinking
about two factors here.
We need to get on the front foot
and have that proactive approach,
and I would say move
away from those tools,
so it's really taking a platform
or a framework based
approach to all of this.
If we kind of just think
about what does this actually look like?
Well, let's just step it back in terms
of what are the kind of core components
of a security strategy.
And look at it in terms of,
I would say investment
profile that goes with it.
The majority of the investment,
in fact the bulk of it
is in that top right hand corner.
It's the layered security controls,
so these are the protection mechanisms
that I talked about earlier,
firewalls, malware, email,
security, web proxies,
that kind of stuff.
And as the kind of threat
landscape has evolved over time
and we know that we can't do
these signature based controls
or kind of looking for basic anomalies,
we've gotta go to this kind of era
where really we need
to look for anomalies,
we need to be able to see some pattern,
some behavior that we haven't seen before
and take action on it.
And this is where kind of
detection response starts coming.
And we've seen some
significant investments
starting happening in this place,
certainly around XDR
capability around SIEM and SAW.
The area that we really wanna focus on
is on the proactive side.
As I mentioned before,
if you can address these things first,
you can significantly
improve the other three.
But surprisingly enough, this is the area
that's got the least amount of spend,
partly because these
tools are disconnected.
But if you take a platform approach
and start to map in your attack surface,
your vulnerability information,
your attack path prediction
and map it in
with what we call the real
time telemetry information,
you're creating almost a,
I would say a cyber fusion platform.
You're marrying real
time alert information
with what a governance
and risk team would use
in terms of exposure information.
And these are the byproducts
that come out of it.
You're gonna prevent
breaches before they occur,
certainly gonna reduce
that incident response
costs in the down downtime
that's associated with it.
And that shift from reactive overspending
to predictive defenses as well.
So, how do you go about doing this?
One approach is you could
build the platform yourself.
Question is, do you have the
time, the money, the expertise?
And you go back to the trap
that I spoke about probably
about half an hour ago,
I think nearly.
Now, you've got all these tools
and you've got the
complexity of managing them.
Or you could look to see what AWS
and Trend Micro are doing in this space
and take a platform
approach that's integrated,
not only from an independent
security vendor like us,
but also with the cloud fabric itself.
And we have a platform called Vision One
that does exactly this.
You think about the
capabilities of the cloud,
a lot of people are looking
at things like C. Napp.
If the platform gives you that
in that top right hand corner,
but also gives you risk information,
say actually we see these
things, this could occur,
then you start to leverage tools
and that telemetered together
to take some proactive action.
So what does actually Vision One give you?
It gives you kind of
three things at its core.
It's about that visibility piece,
giving you a complete picture
across your enterprise.
And what I mean complete picture,
I mean everything from
on-premise, out to the cloud,
and across that full stack,
whether it's infrastructure as a service,
platform as a service,
software as a service, yeah.
It's given you that
prioritization as well.
So we talked about the risks,
talked about the exposure,
that's fine, but where do
you start on that list?
What matters the most?
The platform, because it's
got contextual information
about your business critical assets.
We can start giving you
a list of where to begin
and then go forward from there.
And we'll also give you the mitigations
that go with it as well.
How do I fix this misconfiguration?
Oh how do I change the
permissions on this,
so it's a bit more kind of
acceptable corporate governance?
And when we get this right,
your kind of security platform,
it kind of helps your
business kind of go forward.
It actually becomes ingrained
and becomes a business enabler
for your initiatives, for your programs.
'Cause what we're starting to do now
is we're holistically
managing cyber risk in one go.
We're actually streamlining,
I would say SecOps
or Security Operations with automation
and contextual visibility.
We're strengthening compliance
through automated
reporting and dashboards.
But most importantly,
we're bridging that gap
between leadership and operations
'cause that's where the gap is right now.
That's why security spend or
budget availability is so low
because leadership just
can't see the connection
between I'm spending so much money
on these technology components
and what does it mean
back to the business.
Okay, and we'll see a
practical example of this now.
So this is with Northeast
Georgia Health System,
and I'll just pop the statement
from Stuart Samples, the CTO.
Northeast Georgia Health System
is a regional healthcare
delivery provider.
They're a nonprofit
community health system,
which is based around five
campus hospitals I would say.
They have about 1,000
beds, 1,500 medical staff,
specializing over 60 specialties, right?
It was vital for NGHS to architect
and operate a secure 24/7,
so 24 X 7 solution to meet the needs
of critical operating environment.
And this is an environment
where you've got on-premise,
you've got legacy, you've got
new stuff, you've got that IT,
and you've got OT boundaries as well,
so marrying all of that together.
And you can see from Stuart's statement.
Actually, when he approached
Trend Micro and AWS,
his intention was about risk
reduction was his main goal.
And his kind of biggest area of concern
was the attack surface,
internal and external and
getting a handle on that,
knowing what's out there,
what does the exposure look
like, and what does it mean?
And we can see that these
are the challenges, right?
So he had exactly what I spoke about,
that fragmented visibility
with lots of different tools,
inefficient threat detections,
having to do that manual
correlation every time
and that kind of operational
complexity as well.
Talent resource allocation,
people just doing day in,
day out, alert triage,
not really kind of
doing anything exciting,
not doing any project work,
not kind of driving innovation.
And I think after an extensive study,
they looked at Vision One,
and these are the solutions they took.
They took the cyber risk
exposure management module
to give them that kind of foresight
and understanding what could happen.
They used cloud extensively
so they put the cloud
security elements as well,
endpoint and email.
And then they also took
threat intelligence as well.
So you can see the elements
of the platform coming
together to give that picture.
And these are the kind of
real world business impacts
that they got out of it.
60% reduction in time spent
chasing false positives.
I mean, that's huge on its own.
I would say Trend Vision
One has enabled them
to secure its rapidly growing systems.
Gives them both that proactive
and reactive kind of security strategies,
and gives them a handle on
that attack surface as well,
assessing risk and mitigating
those active threats.
The XDR capabilities
have helped improve the team's efficiency
and providing that centralized
visibility as well.
And again, bottom right hand
corner, simplified reporting
to board of directors,
that's helped them huge
'cause that's now secured some
of their investment profile going forward
for other initiatives that they want.
You can read the full
story on the QR code.
I'll leave it up for a few minutes.
Don't worry, it is good (chuckles).
I know QR codes have
got a bit of an issue,
but no, it is good.
And let's quickly start to wrap this up.
So what have we spoken about?
Cyber risk is a business risk.
I think you can all understand that now
and why it's important.
You've gotta measure it, manage it,
and mitigate it like
any other business risk.
A proactive platform-based approach
is what will drive that resilience,
being able to operate
under stress conditions,
disruption or any kind of outage.
And really what Trend Vision
One and AWS combined together,
really just make it simple.
And if you're up for it
and you can crack the code,
come down to the stand and
you could win $10,000 as well.
I think there might be some Trend people
in the audience as well.
They might have one or two of the numbers
if you ask them nicely, but let's see.
And that's it really.
So I'll open the floor up to any questions
that anyone's got.
No?
In that case, thank you very much.
Enjoy the rest of the day.
(audience applauding)